trouvez en face de moi et le taper à la
loyale comme dans le temps avec des
petits points voilà ce que je te propose
seulement nous 2 à 1 contre 1 100
personnes d'autres tours et ce jour là
avec mes petits points je prendrai
tackle pour attac table peut-être qu'un
jour on sera fixé- match il n'en est pas
prêt pour que ce jour n'arrive jamais
c'est qu'il n'existe pas
[Musique]
m
là
[Musique]
ok là jim écoutez bien ce groupe a
toujours été une famille et la donne
vient de changer
[Musique]
aujourd'hui dominic toretto roule tout
seul tu va tourner le dos à ta famille
je sais que c'est gras mais le lâchez
pas aussi vite c'est notre dernière
chance on va sembler à nouveau notre
famille fais pas ça d'un bref je te
garantis une chose
personne n'est prêt pour ça
elle est l'incarnation même du
terrorisme high tech
il y a des milliers de voitures dans
cette ville et là elle me pistent août
maintenant je sais ce que ressentent les
flics qui nous prennent en chasse
manfred
oh ça craint
l'ong
abu dhabi
cuba nos chemins se sont déjà croisés
d'hommes
sans que tu te rendes coup je crois
qu'il est temps de rappeler pourquoi tu
as choisi d'être ici j'ai pas eu le
choix
pour rattraper d'hommes vous aurez
besoin d'un petit coup il peut me dire
pourquoi tu fais venir ce buveur de thé
avec sa tête de crapule élevé au pudding
je crois que ces tee shirt trop moulant
ça empêche le sang d'aller au cerveau tu
devrais l'être une taille au dessus vous
deux vous allez bosser ensemble
génial
[Musique]
depuis le temps que j'attends ça on a un
tank
c'est à mon tour
yahia a pas
ils ne lâchent jamais la faire
je croyais que ce serait un combat de
rue
[Musique]
tu dors que c'est pas le torpille tient
le voleur quoi
des singles et trop stylées sur ce coup
là oui
je ne fais pas pourquoi tu fais ça mais
je sais une chose c'est que tu m'aimes
fin
ouais ouais les gars
hu
[Musique]